depuis une vingtaine d'années et
souscouvert de lutte contre le
terrorisme ou la criminalité les grandes
puissances sont éperdument lancé dans la
course à la surveillance de masse telle
était donc la démonstration les verraé à
l'instant par ce documentaire réalisé
par Sylvain Loubet une enquête qui
soulève par ailleurs bien des questions
sur cet intense développement des modes
de surveillance nous allons en débattre
maintenant avec nos invités présents
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau de débadoc
Olivier Tesquet est avec nous bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste à l'ebdomadaire
téérama spécialiste du numérique et de
la surveillance et votre dernier ouvrage
à pour titre état d'urgence
technologique il est disponible aux
éditions premier parallèle également
avec nous guillum girud bienvenue à vous
vous êtes ancienne agente du
renseignement français expert en
cyberenseignement vous êtes aujourd'hui
le directeur de la société temno que
vous avez cofondé en 2021 et qui con
soit des outils à destination des forces
de l'ordre visant je cite je cite des
finalités exclusives de protection des
citoyens de quoi parle-t-on exactement
alors quand j'ai défini la vocation de
ma société j'ai voulu dire deux choses à
travers cette expression premièrement je
suis un professionnel de la sécurité
c'est indéniable et je suis fournisseur
de des services de l'État à ce titre
mais ce que j'ai voulu dire aussi c'est
que je conçois tous mes services sur la
base une analyse de ce que de ce dont
ont besoin vraiment les citoyens
c'est-à-dire que je ne prends pas une
technologie et je me dis tiens cette
technologie elle est sympa on peut
surveiller des gens et je je
l'exploiteou dans le concret ça veut
dire que je refuse très régulièrement de
représenter des sociétés qui pour moi
n'ont pas une finalité de protection des
citoyens mais juste une finalité de
surveillance en fait tout simplement on
pourra retrouver tout ce que vous venez
de nous dire he hein bien entendu mais
merci de cette précision et vous êtes
l'auteur de ce livre confidence d'un
agent du renseignement français publié
chez Robert Lafond et puis enfin avec
nous ctiarou bienvenue à vous vous êtes
chargé de plaidoyer liberté chez Amnesty
International France très présent sur
ces sujets hein et vous allez nous
expliquer bien entendu pourquoi à
l'occasion de notre échange je me tourne
vers vous vous avez vu ce ce film nous
l'avons vu ensemble euh quelle morale
tiré finalement d'un d'un film comme
celui-ci sur un sujet anxiogène
terriblement anxiogène lorsqu'on finit
d'avoir vu ce film on s'est dit nous
sommes tous surveillés nous en sommes là
il n'y a pas de garde fous quel al
faut-il tirer du film que nous venons de
voir etz il y a deux choses la première
c'est ce qu'on entend à la toute fin du
du documentaire çair cette question de
comment on remet le génie dans la
bouteille par la question qui nous agite
un peu tous et en fait on se rend compte
que remettre ce fameux génie dans la
bouteille c'est très compliqué une fois
qu'il en est sorti parce qu'il a une
tendance à se se multiplier et devenir
un peu omniscient le génie en question
c'est intéressant vous commenciez par là
ce que je me suis demandé s'il fallait
le remettre dans la bouteille réellement
ce ce ce génie parce qu'il y a tout de
même ces questions de sécurité qui
concernent les les les personnes auquell
elles peuvent être sensibles faut-il
leur mettre complètement dans la
bouteille est-ce est-ce possible
seulement possible aujourd'hui dans
l'état des technologies que nous avons
en face de nous al en fait c'est
toujours possible parce que c'est un
choix politique hein c'est le choix
politique de déployer ou non une
technologie il y a des technologies on
sait qu'elles sont scientifiquement
possibles et c'est pas pour autant qu'on
le fait le le clonage humain est
interdit parce que éthiquement on estime
que c'est pas souhaitable dans une
société démocratique euh mais ce qu'il
faut voir aussi peut-être c'est que
quand on parle de cette surveillance de
masse en fait on sait pas très bien où
on place le curseur il y a beaucoup de
gens qui disent de bonne fois qu'ils ont
rien à cacher parce que bon finalement
ils se sentent pas concernés par des
mesures qui sont présentées vendues
entre guillemets comme des moyens de
lutte contre le terrorisme contre la
criminalité et cetera je pense qu'il y a
un vrai travail collectif à faire pour
redéfinir ce seuil de la surveillance de
masse sortir de la représentation
populaire qu'on en a parfois où la
surveillance de masse ce serait
nécessairement ce qui est très
spectaculaire très intrusif où on voit
les films de science-fiction où on voit
la Chine où on voit voil quelque chose
de très de très visible et de et de qui
pénètre à l'intérieur de l'intimité de
très totalitaire finalement au sens de
vraiment l'intrusion dans l'intimité
alors qu'en réalité aujourd'hui le seuil
de la surveillance de masse à mon sens
c'est considérablement abaissé parce que
les dispositifs sont devenus beaucoup
moins visibles parce qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus pernicieux et qu'en fait
on est soumis dans notre vie quotidienne
à tout un tas de de dispositifs de ce
genre-là qui captent des informations
qui corrèlent des informations entre
elles et qui abaissent ce seuil de la
suspicion qui nous a fait entrer de
plein pied dans ce qu'on pourrait
effectivement considérer comme une air
de la de la surveillance de masse et
aucun pays à ce titre n'est épargné et
hélas non hélas pas en tout cas les les
les démocraties libéral occidental qui
ont largement embrassé ce modèle de
société oui c'est ce qu'on a vu dans
dans ce film effectivement vous en on
avait tiré les mêmes les mêmes leçons de
ce ce film où il y a peut-être d'autres
choses à ajouter alors oui globalement
les mêmes leçons avec d'autres choses
forcément vu de de ma perspective euh je
je pense que l'expression la plus juste
c'est nous sommes entrés dans l'air de
la suspicion de masse et d'ailleurs
c'est dans le titre suspect depuis le 11
septembre 2001 et sous la pression de
nos grands frères américains euh nous
nous sommes nous sommes sommés de
considérer que tout le monde est suspect
et à partir de là les technologies les
plus folles peuvent voir le jour donc
c'est c'est un c'est un il y a vraiment
eu un marqueur un début à cette période
que que moi j'ai j'ai ressenti aussi
dans toute ma carrière et ce qui me
souciit aujourd'hui c'est marqueur c'est
très clairement 2001 septre 2001 oui
pour ma part c'est c'est c'est c'est
sans c'est sans contestte et mais mais
ce qui me ce qui me cause des soucis
aujourd'hui c'est de considérer que
au-delà de ça on a assiste à un avèement
de la technologie dans notre société
queon peut appeler technosolutionnisme
qui a été à l'œuvre dans notre pays
pendant la phase du covid par exemple où
on cherchait des espéments des solutions
technologiques à une épidémie et que c
donc cette aire est en train de s'ouvrir
sur celle de l'intelligence artificielle
aujourd'hui et moi ce dont j'ai
l'impression c'est qu'avant on disait
vous savez la technologie c'est neutre
c'est l'usage qui en est bon ou mauvais
moi j'ai j'ai l'impression vraiment
aujourd'hui que la technologie en train
comme vous le disiez hein le génie est
train de sortir de sa bouteille la
technologie est en train d'échapper au
contrôle et moi je je je je constate
dans mon domaine d'activité que ce sont
les technologues les gens qui
construisent les technologies qui
décident et notamment avec tout le le
système frenchtech c'est-à-dire le le
financement de plus en plus massif et
donc le la la conjonction d'intérêt
entre les les spécialistes de la
technologie et les spécialistes du
financement et moi je vois les
spécialistes comme moi donc qui viennent
vraiment du métier de la sécurité
s'effacer petit à petit au profit de
gens qui n'ont que la technologie en
tête et qui qui forcément ne sont pas
enclin à trouver le bon équilibre en
matière de liberté individuelle pas loin
de penser la même chose hein parce que
j'ai vu dans une interview accordé à
méia part à l'air libre vous disiez la
surveillance la cyber surveillance on a
des outils qui sont incontrôlés un
secteur qui est complètement opaque les
outils de régulation sont inexistants et
donc il faut une réponse politique forte
pour répondre à cette crise vous dites
vous êtes très proche de penser la même
chose que ce qui vient d'être dit là
alors il y il y a effectivement des des
liens avec ce qui vient d'être dit parce
que aujourd'hui et et en faisant écho ce
qui a été dit aussi en en introduction
on voit déjà en fait les impacts de de
de de ces usages de de technologie de
surveillance sur les droits humains ce
qui pour amnestie internationale reste
notre notre référentiel et aujourd'hui
sans se projeter déjà dans une société
complètement dystopique on voit très
bien que les usages qui sont faits par
certains par certains gouvernements de
ces technologies là ont des impacts très
forts sur les droits humains euh les
différentes technologies qui sont
déployées que ce soit pour la
cyberurveillance ciblée que ce soit pour
la surveillance de masse que ce soit
parfois simplement pour la surveillance
du quotidien à travers la captation des
données personnelles par exemple sur les
réseaux sociaux tous ces éléments-l
aujourd'hui on a déjà du recul en
réalité on a déjà documenté l'impact sur
les droits humains les ONG les
journalistes ont publié des rapports des
enquêtes sur l'impact justement euh et
on connaît les les réponses aussi qu'on
pourra apporter le cadre justement qui
doit être posé qui a un cadre
réglementaire qui euh pour certains
domaines n'existe pas du tout pour
d'autres pourrait être posé mais dépend
d'une volonté politique effectivement
d'un choix politique aujourd'hui la
surveillance la surveillance de masse
elle n'est pas compatible avec les
droits humains ça porte atteinte à la
vie privée euh ça ne repose pas sur une
suspicion raisonnable individualisée
d'infraction là on est sur une une
surveillance en fait de de tous à tout
moment dans l'espoir de voir émerger
effectivement potentiellement un risque
on est même dans l'anticipation la
prévention avec la police prédictive où
effectivement on devient tous suspects
potentiel euh à partir de là c'est une
ingérence dans la vie privée qui est
complètement disproportionnée et donc
incompatible avec les droits humains et
il y a pas que ça en terme de problème
ça vient aussi limiter un certain nombre
de libertés fondamentales je pense à la
liberté d'expression à la liberté de
réunion pacifique d'association euh tout
simplement à travers un effet dissuasif
on n'exerce pas ses droits fondamentaux
de la même manière quand on se pense et
qu'on se sait surveiller et le dernier
point peut-être et ça a été très bien
montré dans le documentaire c'est
l'aspect discriminatoire en réalité de
ces technologies effectivement je
rejoins sur le sur l'aspect de la
neutralité euh quand on parle de
discrimination elle est à de niveau à la
fois dans la conception même de l'outil
qui peut emporter les pieds les biaiss
discriminatoires effectivement de de ces
concepteurs et puis ensuite dans l'usage
qui en effet même dans le déploiement de
l'infrastructure de surveillance on a pu
montrer à travers différentes enquêtes
que l'endroit où était placé par exemple
les caméras de vidéosurveillance
n'étaient pas neutre en réalité et
venaient bien souvent amplifier des
pratiques
discriminatoir déjà présente notamment
dans le casadre du maintien de l'ordre
ou de l'application des lois alors j'ai
regardé ce que disait la la la loi
française aujourd'hui pour regarder s'il
y avait tout de même des gardesfous qui
pouvaient un temps soit peu nous
rassurer euh les autorités publiques où
les professionnels doivent obtenir une
autorisation du préfet avant de filmer
la voie publique et les lieux ouverts au
public ça c'est une une chose il faut
demander une autorisation spécifique à
l'acnil la Commission nationale de
l'informatiqu et des libertés hein bien
sûr en cas de dispositif installés pour
identifier les personnes autrement dit
des caméras associé à un système
biométrique la conservation des images
est d'un mois maximum et l'accès aux
images est un droit si vous avez été
filmé autrement dit chaque citoyen s'il
sait qu'il a été filmé est en droit de
demander ses images à certain une
condition on peut lui refuser euh bon là
il y a des gardes fous sur le papier
néanmoins si on parle de notre pays hein
al il y a des gardes fous sur le sur le
papier le le problème quand on est comme
ça dans une dans une
société de la suspicion c'est qu'on on
écrit le droit par la transgression de
la loi finalement c'està-dire que si je
pense par exemple à des technologie de
surveillance qu' on pu être déployé ces
dernières années je pense au drones par
exemple qui ont été censurés par le
Conseil é à censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel euh lors de la loi lors
de la loi sécurité globale qui
finalement ont été retransposé dans un
autre texte et on finit par passer un
peu au un peu au forceps euh on voit que
aujourd'hui c'est technologie là en fait
elles échappent à tout contrôle parce
que on est dans un fonctionnement du
miroir stin c'est-à-dire qu'on a d'un
côté des services spécialisés que ce
soit des services de police ou des
services de renseignement qui peuvent
déployer des outils qui peuvent déployer
de plus en plus d'outils euh de depuis
notamment une loi renseignement de 2015
ils peuvent utiliser dans le cadre de la
l
antiterroriste définition très large un
certain nombre d'outil très intrusifs de
géolocalisation en temps réel de de
logiciel
espion de logiciels qui sont capables de
voir ce que vous frappez sur votre
clavier d'ordinateur enfin voilà des
technologies très très intrusives les
moyens de contrôle qu'on met en face
sont pas du tout à la hauteur que ce
soit sur le contrôle des services de
renseignement ou que ce soit laacnil
Commission Nationale Informatique et
Liberté qui depuis 78 chargé de veiller
justement au respect de la vie privée
des des citoyens il y a même un un petit
verre dans Leme assz inquiétant hein ce
que vous êtes en train de nous dire là
hélas mais depuis le le le le règlement
général sur la protection des données de
2018 qui au niveau européen est venu
quand même à priori renforcer les droits
des citoyens dans l'espace communautaire
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui pour
mener un certain nombre
d'expérimentations parce que ça se fait
souvent sur ce régime là il y a plus
d'obligation de déclaration préalable il
y a un principe de responsabilité
c'est-à-dire que le contrôle se se fait
à postériori mais comment le contrôle se
fait à postériori quand vous avez une
autorité administr indépendante comme
laacnil qui a pas les moyens de mener
ses contrôle là on a l'exemple récent de
cette enquête de disclose sur
l'utilisation de la reconnaissance
faciale par la police en France ce qu'on
suputait un peu depuis quelques temps
parce que quand on achète des logiciels
à des entreprises étrangères que ces
logiciels sont capables de faire de la
reconnaissance faciale et qu'on nous dit
non vous inquiétez pas on n pas actionné
on n' pas activé la fonctionnalité du
coup on est obligé de les croire sur
parole parce qu'on a pas de moyens de
contrôle et on n pas non plus de moyens
de contrôle nous dans notre activité
journalistique par exemple c'estàdire
que moi le nombre de fois où j'ai fait
des demandes d'accès à des documents
administratifs qui sont théoriquement
communicables H qui sont d'intérêt
public et où on m'a dit non parce que un
coup c'est secret défense un coup on l'a
pas ou parce que juste les les
ministères concernés ne les transmettent
pas ça crée une asymétrie terrible qui
fait que bah ces servicesl ont un blanc
sain pour utiliser ce type de
technologie et on se retrouve dans des
situations comme celle décrite par
l'enquête de disclose ça fait des
scandales alors on va y revenir ce sont
des systèmes qui passent sous les radars
en réalité il y a pas qu'en France il y
a aussi aux États-Unis on va écouter
claire garvy chercheuse à l'Université
de Georgetown c'est un extrait du
documentaire en 2016 nous avons déposé
des demandes d'accès à des documents
publics dans plus de 100 juridiction à
travers le pays demandant simplement
quelle données biométrique y était
conservé et nous avons découvert que
plus de la moitié des Américains
aujourd'hui dans une base de données de
reconnaissance faciale utilisée dans les
enquêtes criminelles et ce uniquement
grâce à leur permis de conduire ou à
leur carte d'identité et ça personne ne
le savait plus de la moitié des
Américains aujourd'hui figurent dans une
base de données de reconnaissance
faciale utilisé pour les enquêtes
criminelles voilà la conclusion à
laquelle en est arrivé cette chercheuse
américaine
ou là on passe sous les radars ça
illustre parfaitement bien ce qui vient
d'être dit concernant la situation en
France he tel que vous l'avez perçu oui
alors il y a il y a plusieurs sujets
dans ce qu'on entend là le moi le
premier sujet qui m'interpelle depuis
longtemps c'est que aux États-Unis il y
a eu une sorte de
banalisation du détournement des
dispositifs réglementaires par les
services spécialisés hein on c'est ce
que je dis tout à fait public on sait
que le FBI maintenant détourne depuis
longtemps euh toutes les lois donc
notamment je crois c'est la loi 702 sur
renseignement au aux États-Unis et et a
obtenu des moyens de blanchiment des
informations de renseignement
c'est-à-dire que le FBI achète des
informations de renseignement comme une
société privé en fait un usage à des
fins de renseignement euh j'ai envie de
dire on n est pas là en France euh il
Fautre vigilant mais on en est pas là
pour la bonne raison que les plateformes
sont aux États-Unis en général hein donc
ça ça nous ça limite un peu nos actions
euh sur le sujet ensuite de la de la
vidéosurveillance euh il y a quelques
notions techniques à apporter au débat
bas pour pour bien comprendre euh déjà
vidéosurveillance c'est pour les lieux
privés donc dans l'espace public on dit
vidéo protection euh il y a plusieurs
degrés euh la vidéo protection qui
consiste à filmer un espace et à le
retransmettre sur le sur le l'écran d'un
agent qui va regarder le flux vidéo ça
c'est c'est autorisé c'est c'est
réglementé comme vous dites il y a il y
a un droit d'accès des citoyens
théoriquement oui j'ai moi je l'ai déjà
exercé sur sur donc il existe après bon
il y a il existe B ex Il existe voilà
ouais euh tout en haut du spectre il y a
la biométrie la reconnaissance faciale
et effectivement ça c'est le sans doute
le dispositif le plus attentatoire aux
libertés et moi en tant que citoyen je
je me refuse à vivre dans un dans un
pays où où il y a une reconnaissance
faciale sans sans recherche de finalité
précise euh ce qui est compliqué
aujourd'hui et je pense ce qui ce qui
jou j'ai bien compris he les logiciels
pour leonnaance faciale euh sont utilisé
à discrétion par des services de
sécurité de renseignement euh et c'est
là que ça passe sous les radard
finalement oui alors avant de répondre à
votre question je je je je finis juste
entre entre ces deux extrêmes il y a ce
qu'on appelle la reconnaissance
algorithmique et aujourd'h pour les j ça
ça ça sera autorisé pour les j hein 2024
et si moi si je si je comprends bien
c'est le en gros c'est la fonctionnalité
qui est aujourd'hui activée dans dans le
dans le dispositif que disclose révèle
au grand publ c'est-à-dire que c'est une
utilisation de reconnaissance
algorithmique mais qui nécessite tout de
même comme ça a été dit euh une donc ça
nécessite une étude d'impact avec un
dépôt de dossier auprès de laacnil qui
bon on va voir comment le ministère de
l'Intérieur communique sur ce sujet je
je sais pas si ça a été fait euh pour
revenir à à votre question ou ce que
vous dites a été institué dans dans la
loi qui a été taillé sur mesure pour les
JO de 2024 et précisément donc j'ai moi
j'ai participé au au au travaux du Sénat
euh sur le sujet euh euh la
reconnaissance faciale a été exclue oui
du périmètre de la loi donc elle ne sera
pas utilisée pour les Jos et je rappelle
que la loi c'est une loi qui qui qui
dispose une une expérimentation du
dispositif et donc il y a d'autres
dispositifs qui sont en cours de
discussion mais jusqu'en 2025 la
reconnaissance faciale est exclue en
revanche la recance algorithmique est
autorisée cette subtilité cette HE
technique il faut bien comprendre he
entre les deux types de de de vidéos
surveillance le Crédit social ne sera
autorisé qu'avec la reconnaissance
faciale qui permet d'identifier à coup
sûr un individu ouais oui moi je je veux
bien réagir parce que je trouve que la
position finalement de dirc de la alors
n on parle de vidéosurveillance
algorithmique dans dans dans l'espace
public hein les termes vidéoprection ou
caméra augmenté ou intelligente on
considère que ça vient quand même
connoter un petit peu le le les termes
les termes du débat on parle
concrètement en fait d'algorithmes qui
vont analyser les images issues de
vidéos sur surveillance pour détecter
des événements qu'ils sont entraînés à
repérer et ensuite signaler aux
autorités la la la situation on a
également
participé aux discussions parlementaires
au moment de la loi la loi Jo euh on a
dénoncé le le le dispositif de
vidéosurveillance algorithmique tel
qu'il est il a été adopté dans le cadre
de la loi Jo parce qu'on considère que
même sans la reconnaissance faciale qui
est de fait exclue mais pas interdite et
c'est une subtilité sur laquelle il
faudra peut-être vir euh même sans la
reconnaissance faciale le dispositif
comporte des risques en matière de
droits humains on considère qu'il n'y a
pas de garantie technique ou juridique
pour complètement éradiquer ce risque là
et à partir de là la démonstration de la
nécessité de la proportionnalité en fait
du dispositif qui est une obligation au
regard du droit international n'a pas
été faite on nous a dit ces technologies
sont efficass pour lutter contre la
criminalité pour lutter contre le
terrorisme en plus elles sont
disponibles voilà utilisons-les on n'
pas eu la démonstration qu'il n'y avait
pas par exemple de moyens moins
attentatoir aux liberté pour atteindre
l'objectif légitime de de sécurité y
compris dans le cadre d'un événement
comme comme les j maintenant cette
question de la reconnaissance faciale
qui a été exclu on a bien vu quelques
semaines après à la faveur d'une
proposition de loi du Sénat qu'elle
revenait avec un principe d'interdiction
qui était posé au début et puis ensuite
tout un tas d'exceptions qui finalement
créent une base légale pour
l'utilisation de de cette technologie là
euh c'est une proposition de loi qui
prévoit un test sur 3 ans hein si j'ai
bien compris euh oui alors ça c'est
aorisation de reconnaissance faciale
pour un certain nombre de services c'est
ça mais alors renseignement police c'est
une autre dimension le le côté
expérimental qui est toujours avancé que
ce soit dans la loi Jo ou ou
ailleurs il est il est aussi à
questionner c'estàdire que bien souvent
euh par une généralisation ex
expérimental aussi voilà donc
l'expérimental tion dure et et perdure
et finalement s'installe et rentre dans
rentre dans le droit commun et puis on
voit bien dans les débats européens
actuellement en ce moment même sur le
règlement UE sur l'intelligence
artificielle la France très clairement
pousse pour ne pas interdire les
systèmes d'identification
biométriqu et donc effectivement là on a
on a quand même un un double discours
entre d'un côté dire on exclut la
reconnaissance faciale qui est agité
presque comme un chiffon rouge c'est
devenu une ligne rouge dans le débat
parlementaire sur lo J et ensuite on se
rend compte à la faveur des révélations
du disclose à travers une PPL qui est
une proposition de loi qui est déposée
voilà au Sénat ou encore avec le le la
positionnement de le positionnement de
la France au sein de du Conseil de l'UE
qu'en fait on est encore très très loin
de cette interdiction là ouais d'autant
plus que vous vous l'avez évoqué à
plusieurs reprises cette enquête de no
nos confrères de
disclose qui en fait révèle que la
police nationale a utilisé et utilise
hein au moment où nous nous parlons
également un logiciel israélien de
reconnaiss s faciale il s'appelle
briefcam ce logiciel il a été testé en
2017 puis généralisé dans dans divers
service de police du rô du Nord des
albes Maritimes de hautegaron il y a
200 200 municipalités qui se servirait
française he qui se servirait de ce
logiciel aujourd'hui et l'acnil dit ne
pas pouvoir prouver par A+ B que ce
logiciel fait bien de la reconnaissance
faciale et quant à la direction générale
de la police
no comment mais elle elle ne démand pas
ce qu'on savait déjà c'est que briefcam
vend et de manière assez officielle il
suffit d'aller par exemple au salon
Milipol qui se tient tous les 2 ans au
parc des expositions de ville peinte et
vous avez tous les les les
professionnels de la sécurité de tous
les pays qui qui proposent le leur leurs
outils et leurs services à des services
spécialisés de France ou d'ailleurs et
briefcam avait un stand et briefcam euh
vous savait vender à des à des à des
municipalités ou des ou des
collectivités françaises un outil de
vidéosurveillance algorithmique ou en
gros le fonctionnement c'est que vous
mettez un certain nombre d'heures
d'image et dans ces heures d'images le
logiciel va identifier les les moments
saillants qui méritent d'être regardés
de plus près et qui sont peut-être des
des incidents maintenant on sait que
voilà il y a la fameuse petite
fonctionnalité supplémentaire qui peut
être activé moi il y a quelque chose qui
m'interpelle quand même beaucoup dans ce
dans ce glissement parce que c'est bien
de ça dont il s'agit on est passé dans
les années 90 on a eu l'arrivée de la
vidéosurveillance ensuite maintenant on
a la vidéosurveillance algorithmique on
voit que le le le le le en bout de ligne
on a la question de la reconnaissance
faciale qui serait
l'évolutionouement assez logique on y va
tout droit et à chaque fois on nous dit
pas tout de suite mais bon ça ce n'est
qu'une question de temps finalement et
dans un moment où on nous vend ça sous
les oripos du du scientisme le plus
absolu en fait il y a aucune rationalité
dans ces décisions là c'est-à-dire que
ce qu'il faut voir et pour le coup ça
vient pas d'un repère de gauchiste c'est
quand même la la Cour des comptes qui
depuis des années demande un bilan
sérieux euh de la
vidéosurveillance bilan sérieux qui n'a
jamais été fait et donc on est face à
une technologie qui ne démontre
absolument pas son efficacité voire
démontre son inefficacité la seule la
rare étude qu' a eu sur la
vidéosurveillance l'année dernière a
montré qu'elle était utile dans 1 % des
cas à peu près pour l'élucidation des
des enquêtes criminelles et c'est cette
situation où moins la technologie est
efficace plus on va décider de mettre en
place l'itération plus intrusive de
cette même technologie ce qui est même
je trouve le signe d'une d'une d'une
emprise de la technologie sur nos nos
décideurs politiques qui est assez
inquiétante il y en a eu il y en a qui
ont moins d'état d'âme vis-à-vis de la
la reconnaissance faciale sont les
Chinois ça sera le dernier extrait de
notre
documentaire récemment l'Empire du
Milieu a décidé de mettre la société au
pas en instaurant un système de notation
qui récompense ou pénalise les citoyens
en fonction de leur
comportement un système baptisé crédit
social
dans unedé
[Musique]
pagique率省社會所社會成員建立信用檔案依據信用分數高低劃分為aa到六個等級我是a信用等級有什麼機措施你可以參與平先進平職稱發展黨員享受
vous disziez tout à l'heure en bout de
course il y aura sans doute la
reconnaissance faciale est-ce qu'en bout
de course il y aura pas ce fameux Crédit
Social utilisé en Chine là on est dans
ce qu'on peut appeler le
totalitarisme numérique en Chine
surveillance de masse grâce à la
reconnaissance faciale ou là c'est c'est
c'est l'extrême là on a c'est la fin du
voyage en quelque sorte bon je moi je
sais pas ce que je souhaite je connais
personne qui souhaite
ça on a on a quand même des des gardeses
fous dans dans notre dans notre droit
dans notre droit national dans not droit
supranational j'imagine pas qu'on qu'on
y arrive qu'on y qu'on y arrive très
facilement quand même il faut il faut
quand même toujours garder à l'esprit
que cette technologie sert un modèle de
société qui n'est pas du tout le nôtre
et précis
totalitaire on voit on on voit tout à
fait le l'utilisation que peuvent en
faire peut faire de ces technologies des
état totalitaire la Chine étant très
largement le plus puissant d'entre eux
aujourd'hui tout à fait si si un
professionnel comme moi s'est engagé
dans la sécurité c'est précisément pour
protéger notre modèle de société moi je
je chéris le modèle de société dans
lequel on vit où on peut échanger
s'informer euh s'exprimer librement et
la sécurité il faut quand même garder à
l'esprit que la sécurité dans notre pays
est est là pour finalité de nous
protéger contre des tentatives de
déstabilisation possiblement par ces
régimes et que qu'il faut donc s'y
opposé de toutes ces forces parliz du
droit international évidemment ou alors
là l'exemple chinois on peut rien faire
alors ça c'est une très CLA alors là
c'est uneation très clair effectivement
de de comment euh un un état répressif
un gouvernement répressif peut se saisir
de technologie euh à des fins
effectivement euh là pour le coup tout à
fait
discriminatoire vendre C technologie à
d'autres états totalitaires c'est le cas
de la Chine en Uganda par exemple je
pourrais citer beaucoup d'autres pays
hein a qui sont cités dans le film je
pourrais peut-être aussi citer une
entreprise française par exemple qui a
vendu ses technologies de surveillance à
qui à la Chine donc il faut aussi faire
attention à j'ai noté son nom je l'ai
pas sous les yeux ilemiaia voilà on
avait documenté comment en 2015
effectivement c'est ces technologie
technologie là avait été vendu au bureau
de sécurité publique de shangï c'est que
là on est mais très clairement on voit
le très bien le contexte dans lequel il
peut être utilisé donc cette entreprise
Française contribue à ah bah une
responsabilité énorme effectivement
alors elle a mis fin à ces à à ces
exportations là mais tout ça pour dire
qu'en fait la responsabilité elle est
elle est énorme et elle est partout
c'estd que les les entreprises
effectivement du secteur doivent
évidemment mener un devoir de vigilance
et s'assurer que ces technologie là
leurs technologies ne seront pas
utilisées pour commettre des violations
des droits humains mais en France et et
tous les états aujourd'hui en fait la
dérive elle est toujours possible
aujourd'hui si on pose pas des principes
d'interdiction clair en réalité on peut
tout à fait on parlait de glissement
tout à l'heure tout à fait imaginer que
si un un un gouvernement répressif ou
avec d'autres intentions arrivent au
pouvoir demain en fait il a tous les
outils nécessaires à disposition le
cadre législatif tout qui va bien pour
justement en fait pouvoir mener une
politique potentiellement liberticide et
répressive et donc c'est aujourd'hui
qu'il faut poser ces cars de fou parce
qu'une fois que les technologies sont là
on les utilise et on va généralement pas
revenir en arrière ou on revient jamais
en arrière c'est ce que prouve
l'histoire en réalité he sur ces
questions merci vraiment à tous les
trois hein d'avoir participé à ce débat
doc aujourd'hui consacré à la
surveillance de masse sujet anxiogène et
on a essayé de de de d'en débattre entre
nous pour essayer de de voir jusqu'à
quel point il y a il y a il y a tout de
même des gardes de fous possibles
j'espère qu'on aura rassuré ceux et
celles qui ont regardé ce documentaire
et entendu
nos échanges vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtagdbadoc en tout cas elles seront
nombreuses je l'imagine vous serez là
d'ailleurs j'espère he pour réagir à ce
que sont ces ses réactions merci à Selma
sali et également Sarah Eline qui m'ont
aidé à préparer cette émission je vous
donne rendez-vous bien sûr pour un
prochain débadoc et ça sera toujours
avec son documentaire et son débat à
très
[Musique]
bientôt